what's happening reject nation greg and
john here today i hear you guys some of
your like might want to cool in on some
of those spider-man no way home videos
we hear you loud and clear so today
we're going to watch the first trailer
for the sequel to spider-man into the
spider-verse called part one spider-man
across the spider versus heart one so
what what does that mean this is gonna
be a two-part movie two-parter movie
what
they're going big they're like
top spider-man no way home with our
sequence of the best arguable spider
anime who do it double big the argument
often tends to be is it the live-action
spider-man 2 or to the spider-verse
which one's the better one you guys tell
us down below before we get into that
this video is sponsored by hanukkah
don't forget about the jews this
christmas season
jesus wouldn't want you to
good to be back
oh [ __ ]
you got a minute oh
whoa
when how did how did she
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in
it it is
my dorm room is
very adorable right no of course
are these your drawings what no no good
oh
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i
i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
i'm
grounded
okay
yeah
you're spiderman is spiderman grounded
um
i mean
hell yeah
come on man
go for it
yeah
awesome
circuits of time duder
and multiverse
wow
yes
i'm so happy
god i love the art
yo
that post-credits team must actually be
figuring
yeah
absolutely
beautiful october 7th what a time to be
a spider-man fan absolutely what a time
to be a spider-man fan well this one too
is just so you know because it doesn't
have the same like constant hype train
is no way home like this does sort of
pierce through as something extra
special especially during the holidays i
remember when the first one was coming
out spider-man fans were excited for it
it didn't have as broad of an appeal as
a usual live-action spider-man movie
would but then when it was released the
word of mouth on that first one was to
take
the roof and it just started collecting
money and winning awards yeah yeah and i
feel like this one will have
exceptionally more hype versus the uh
the the initial debut of the
spider-verse when it came out uh years
ago right looking at this though i love
right where it's picking up it just it
has that flavor of like the animation
that was so dazzling before and that's
all present here the t's of like miguel
o'hara uh spider-man 2099 i hope it's
oscar isaac back in the role how cool
would that be if you had because i think
it was him at the post-credits scene
right who's going to be moon night now
dude he's everywhere
in the marvel world and hopefully miles
actually is able to snag gwen as his
girlfriend this time around but he looks
older yes
yeah you know his hair has grown a
little bit you know and i always love
when animation could do that when it
actually feels like oh yeah a little
time has passed it's not like obvious
you know like a beer or something but
yeah he does look a little bit older a
little more mature in the animation
style and two just watching as they go
even further down the rabbit hole of
making the animation feel alive and like
it's you know blasting through various
different approaches to the medium and
doing all this stuff that looks like old
pop art and old like comic strips out of
newspapers like all that's been in here
but basically augmented to a whole new
level at least it looks like here like
when he's swinging through the
multiverse that looked like a
transportive experience yeah i think
it's cool how the first movie was all
about spider-man coming into his world
his earth and now it's appropriate it's
called part one because there's so many
different universes he can explore oh
yeah so to be going across this and to
see like i'm looking forward to seeing
how not only the other spider-man that
we're going to encounter or whatever
spider-man are brought back from the
first one but to see how they visually
realize the other worlds i hope they
really double down on the aesthetics
there and really bring some different
planets to life oh yeah absolutely
different cities to life see different
versions of new york and whatnot while i
guess dealing with his
father grounding him at home instead of
his mother
jefferson's going to be pissed yeah
because if he's going across universes
you know maybe he can be multiple
versions of himself
this time around absolutely has he
mainly met peter parker's before his
possibilities are endless and yeah like
it seems like now that the first movie
was so successful i have to imagine they
feel emboldened to do just about
anything in terms of what wild spiderman
related dreams you could entertain well
i mean looking back at it they got
different directors this time around
this one's written by phil lord chris
miller and dave callahan everyone always
looks at this is the phil lauren chris
miller movie but not even the first one
was hey caleb was on the same script
their fingerprints were all over it yeah
the directors are the first three those
aren't the same directors at all
which is interesting to me because i
mean you know jessica drew is going to
be in this yeah
jessica all right which is the one thing
we didn't really get a tease over this
trailer which is it's funny because the
imdb for this is so spare right now yeah
that seems like a pretty big one to at
least draw anticipation for i'm hearing
rumors about who the villain might
potentially be i heard rumblings that it
could possibly be mr negative this time
around where if you guys played the
spider-man ps4 game that was i think his
most recent
and then some type of animated medium
that might be that one that's where i'm
most familiar with the character so that
would be cool to realize and when you're
dealing with multiverse stuff and that
type of power set that he has it would
feel appropriate but either way i was
excited that this movie this franchise
gets to live on what are your to be
spider-man fans not only are we getting
morbius but now we're getting spider-man
and spy versus next year now a constant
coverage like yes every trailer teaser
tv spot poster we're not going to run
out of content ever never never break
from spider-man guys subscribe to the
real rejects hit that like button uh
check out all our other spider-man
videos and let's do a pic
eric horseman i was going through my
instagram and i was going through uh
like all the old photos when you go down
memory lane and you're like oh my god i
hated myself back then and then i came
across
your tattoo that you got of the real
rejects logo which is no longer the logo
that we used but you got a tattoo of the
real rejects logo on your arm and we
haven't talked in a long time and then
it started making me wonder just how
funny it is how much you must regret
that
like my goodness
we have it's been we've been so busy and
we haven't just discussed anything
proper in a while and here you are
rocking this tattoo that you got in
honor of us it's like we're completely
absent in your life i know i just saw an
instagram post about a company that
covers up tattoos with other things once
you go through a breakup and i'm like
eric you're gonna have to get it like a
whole arm oh man
screw yeah dude
we better keep your interest alive
because in four or five years you're
gonna be like damn i just better peel
all the skin off this arm and all
sincerity it did really make me go we
gotta travel to atlanta one day just to
meet you trust me if you're ever in your
dying bed i'm going
that's all it takes i want to hear your
last words a little bit like i gotta go
now all guilts gotta go
i love you buddy merry christmas